PROFESSOR: All right.
Let's get started.
So we are continuing the
theme of unfolding polyhedra,
and the general picture we are
thinking about in terms of edge
unfolding versus
general unfolding which
are these two pictures.
Top is an edge
unfolding of the cube.
Bottom is a general
If you have a
complex polyhedron,
we found general unfoldings.
There are like four of them.
They work.
We proved one of them.
If you want an edge
unfolding, that's
the centuries-old open problem.
For non-convex
polyhedra, we know
this is too much to hope for.
Even if it's
topologically convex,
there's not always
an edge unfolding.
That was the
tetrahedral Witch's Hat.
But for general
unfolding, we don't know.
So today's lecture is actually
mostly about these two
open problems and
different variations of it
that we know how to
solve, special cases,
and changes in the model.
At the end, there'll
also be some stuff
about the reverse
direction folding,
but mostly, it will
be about unfolding.
So there's a third
kind of unfolding
which we call vertex
unfolding, and it's
kind of like a
hinged dissection.
So instead of normally
in unfolding, something
like a cross, it's a
nice, connected polygon.
The faces are
joined along edges.
But what if I allowed
disconnecting along edges,
but I just wanted things to
stay connected along vertices,
like at a hinge.
So it still should be
one piece in the sense
that this is still
connected, and in this case,
I still want an edge unfolding.
You're only allowed
to cut on edges.
And in fact, we will
cut on all the edges
because that'll be
the most flexible.
Every edge gets cut,
but you're going
to leave intact certain
vertices to make one, quote,
"piece" at vertices.
So we still want one piece.
So this is vertex unfolding,
and it's always possible.
We've even implemented
this algorithm here.
A bunch of random
points on a sphere.
Take the convex hull, and
then, take a vertex unfolding.
So you get this nice
chain of triangles,
don't intersect each other,
and this will fold up
into that 3D
polyhedron on the left.
Here's some bigger examples,
hundreds of vertices.
Amazing.
All right.
So how do we do this?
Let me state a theorem.
Every connected
triangulated manifold--
this is a very general result.
It actually holds
in any dimension.
We're going to think about
two dimensional sources in 3D,
but it could be D
dimensional surfaces
in D plus 1 dimensions.
--has a vertex unfolding.
So this works both for
convex and for non-convex.
The only catch is that every
face has to be a triangle.
It's an open problem
for something
like a cube where you actually
have quadrilateral faces.
So the way we prove
this is to construct
what we call a facet-path.
This is a path that
alternates between visiting
faces, triangles, and vertices.
So the idea is you
have some-- say
we're doing a
tetrahedron or something.
You start at a facet.
Then, you go to one
of its vertices.
Then, you go to one of the
facets that shares that vertex.
Then, you go to one
of the vertices.
Then, you go to a facet.
Then, you go to a vertex.
This is a facet-path.
It should visit every facet,
every triangle, exactly once.
Vertices you can
visit multiple times,
although I think it's a bad idea
to visit the same vertex twice
in a row.
Other than that, you can
visit a vertex more than once.
Maybe I would visit it
again coming up here.
If there was another
triangle like this,
I could go up to this vertex
again and over to the triangle.
So the claim is
facet-paths always
exist for any triangulated,
connected surface.
Once you have this
facet-path, you're
basically golden because you
can lay it out without overlap.
And that's the next picture.
So if you have a triangle and
you have some corners of it
that are hinged to
adjacent triangles,
you can rotate
that triangle 'til
it fits in a vertical slab.
And the hinges are on
the ends of the slab.
And so each triangle
lives in its own slab.
Slabs don't intersect.
No intersection.
The hard part is really
getting this path.
Once you have that, you
can just lay it out.
It's a little bit nontrivial
with obtuse triangles.
They don't necessarily just
lie along the horizontal line.
You have to set things
up so that those guys are
on the boundary,
but you can always
rotate it so that
that's possible.
So the real question is, how
do we construct a facet-path?
All right.
So I have a bunch of triangles.
In general, they
make some surface.
And maybe I should draw a
running example over here.
Let's think about a triangulated
cube, something simple.
Imagine there's more
triangles in the back.
It's a little hard to
think about the 3D picture.
I would really like to
two dimensionalify it,
and because this
theorem works, not only
for a polyhedron-- it works
for any manifold, any sort
of locally, two dimensional
thing-- it would be nice
if I could just sort
of cut this open
and think about a disc instead
of a sphere, topologically.
And I can.
I mean this theorem's supposed
to work for discs just as well.
It should work for
anything that's connected.
So ideally, I cut it all apart
into lots of little triangles,
but it has to stay connected.
So I'll unfold it.
Why not?
So I can add some
cuts until I get down
to a spanning tree of the
faces, a spanning tree
of the dual graph.
OK.
For whatever reason, this is
the triangulation I chose,
and this is the
unfolding I chose.
But just keep cutting
edges until cutting an edge
would cause it to disconnect.
So the maximal set of cuts,
there are many ways to do it.
When I unfold, it might
overlap because we
don't know whether
edge unfoldings exist,
but that's fine.
You can think of it as a
two dimensional picture,
but it might need a few layers.
We're not going to
actually fold this thing,
but we're going to cut
this up into a facet-path.
This could actually
be our input.
Instead of being
given a polyhedron,
we're given a disc like
this, a triangulated disc,
and we have to deal with it.
Somehow we've got to
construct a facet-path here,
visit every triangle
exactly once,
and passing through vertices.
AUDIENCE: So if
you have overlap,
it doesn't really matter.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, overlap
doesn't really matter.
We're going to cut it
up, and then, we're
going to splay
out the triangles.
AUDIENCE: Distances
don't matter.
Right?
PROFESSOR: No, uh.
AUDIENCE: If you're trying
to just find a path--
PROFESSOR: Right.
From the perspective
of facet-path,
distances don't matter.
It's just topology.
Yeah.
You could think of it as a
circle with some decomposition
into triangles, if you like,
but that's maybe harder
to think about.
I got to think
about it this way.
It's useful because then,
we'll get to Mickey Mouses,
as we'll see.
So cut edges until
you can't anymore,
so until cutting
would disconnect.
So this means what
you're left with
will be sort of a tree of faces.
There'll be no cycles
because if there was a cycle,
you could cut one of the edges,
and it wouldn't fall apart.
So obviously,
there's a tree here.
Now, trees have leaves.
That's our favorite
lemma lately.
They have at least two leaves.
In the case of a
triangulated polygon,
we usually call them ears.
So here's a fun term.
So let's say color the ears.
These are leaves and in that
tree which call the dual tree.
So in reality, we're thinking
about a dual graph which
looks something like
this, where there's
a vertex for every triangle and
edges for every edge connecting
triangles, and there's
leaves of that tree.
But in the original thing,
we think of this triangle
as being an ear, and
this triangle is an ear.
And this triangle is an ear,
and this triangle is an ear.
I like ears because they're
kind of on the boundary,
on the surface, so
they're just triangles
that are adjacent to
only one other triangle.
Now, the next step
is to color what
are called the
second-level ears.
I'll call them the
remaining ears,
if you remove those ears, what
would, then, become an ear.
All right.
Now, I wish I had another color.
Yeah, that's kind of yellowish.
So this would become an ear.
This would become an ear.
This would become an ear,
and this would become an ear.
And I'm going to stop
there, just two levels.
What could I get
in this process?
I mean what it looks
like I'm getting
is I get an ear and
then, a second-level ear.
It could be a little
more general than that.
Maybe, for example, if I
had a triangle like this,
both of these would
be first-level ears,
and then, this would
become a second-level ear.
Turns out that's
all that can happen.
Because these are
triangles, second-level ear,
at this point, it's only
adjacent to one other thing.
So what was it
adjacent to before?
Well, maybe, one
ear, certainly not
zero because it wasn't
a first-level ear.
So at least one
ear, maybe two ears.
That's it.
AUDIENCE: Unless there's
only four pieces left.
Right?
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
what do you mean?
AUDIENCE: You could
have three ears.
PROFESSOR: You could
have three years.
Yeah, so here I have two.
I mean the first-level
ear and a second-level,
or it could be a first-level--
Oh, you're saying at the end.
Right.
It could be like this.
That would only happen
at the very end.
But yeah, this could
be first-level ears,
and this is the
second-level ear.
Good point.
Most of the time, we
will either get something
like this, the rest of
the polygons over here--
so this is a first-level ear.
This is a second-level ear.
--or I get-- this is the
Mickey Mouse picture.
Probably not allowed
to say Mickey Mouse.
It's under copyright,
but there you go.
So two first-level
ears, second-level ear.
Boom.
This is, most of the
time, what you'll
get in the base case
of this induction.
I'm going to pluck
off these ears
and keep making
the thing smaller.
At the end, there are a
few cases to think about.
I have them drawn here
somewhere, base cases.
Nothing.
Yeah, well.
This won't work out if
you have one triangle,
if you have zero triangles,
which is this empty picture,
or if you just have two maybe.
Well, I guess--
Yeah, because then,
these are both first-level ears.
It doesn't look quite the same.
Or maybe just a Mickey Mouse
because those are all-- Well,
it probably works.
Anyway, these are the sort
of cases you worry about.
But for these cases,
I just need to check
that I can find a facet-path.
So for example, this one,
I just visit the triangle.
This one-- I don't
know-- I do it like that.
In fact, I can make it a
cycle if I want to go crazy.
This one-- I don't know--
something like this.
That'd be one way to do it.
(SINGING) Doo, doo, doo.
Hm.
Got to be a little careful.
[INAUDIBLE]
Something like that.
All right.
But really, I care
about these two cases.
So what I'm going to
do for each of those--
I guess this is
still step four--
is I actually want to make
cycles for these guys.
I care about that.
Am I doing something wrong?
Oh, no.
Over there.
Good.
So in both of these
cases, I can make cycles.
In this one, in the
base cases, not always.
Like this guy, hard
to make a cycle.
But for the two
general cases, if I
find two ears or three ears,
I can just draw that in.
So I'll do that for this
example, though, by now,
it's gotten a little
messy, so let me redraw it.
So we have-- All right.
So I'm going to connect these
guys and connect these guys.
This case, I only
get the two-ear case,
but I think we'll get
another case shortly.
OK?
So obviously, I haven't finished
it, and these are disconnected.
There's lots of
things left to do.
But then, the idea is repeat.
So imagine those
guys as being done.
I'm left with these
four triangles,
actually, a little
boring because I
don't get the Mickey Mouse case.
But then, this will be an ear.
This will be a second-level ear.
And so I'll end up doing this.
And this will be
an ear, and this
will be an ear,
second-level here.
I mean this is actually
the base case, if you will.
So in general, I just pluck
off two or three triangles,
repeat until I get
one of the base cases.
Now, what I have
is not connected,
but it's a bunch of cycles.
But there's one cycle here, one
cycle there, one cycle there.
You could actually
connect some of them
together, like these two.
You could go around like
this and then, go like that,
so that could be a bigger cycle.
But these cycles are not even
attached to these cycles,
so it's kind of a problem.
That's step five is we're
going to fix all the problems.
That'd be a great title.
Connect cycles together.
We're going to do that
by local switches,
so here's the general picture.
Suppose you have two adjacent
triangles and two completely
separate paths.
So it's a cycle, so
some cycle over here.
And if this guy shared
a vertex, then I
could actually
connect them together.
So suppose it doesn't
share a vertex.
That means it has
to use these two,
and then, it--
something like that.
What I want to do is remove
this edge and remove this edge
and, instead, add this
edge and that edge.
So that's a local change, and
now, it will be one big cycle.
We've probably seen
this trick once or twice
before, I think in the Mountain
Valley assignment stuff.
So here I have, for example,
these two triangles,
which are adjacent, but
the paths don't meet.
So I'm just going to erase
this edge, put in that one,
erase this edge,
put in that one.
Lo and behold, I have a
bigger cycle now, like that.
Still not everything, so
like these two triangles
don't touch.
So erase that edge.
Erase that edge.
Put in that one.
I'm preserving, at all
times, that I'm a facet path,
and I'm merging components.
So by the end, I'll
have one big component.
Now, I haven't necessarily
described this as a big cycle,
but as I've kind of been
hinting, what I do now
is take an Euler tour
around this thing.
We've seen Euler tours.
All the vertices in this
graph will have even degree.
And so I can take an
Euler tour, and really, I
should take what's called
a non-crossing Euler tour.
Point is you've got a
bunch of cycles that touch.
You just walk
around the outside.
That will visit all the cycles.
It'll visit all these
edges exactly once,
and that will actually
be a facet-path.
And we're done.
Now, I have a facet-path
for a triangulated cube.
So I can splay out
those triangles,
get a non-overlapping
chain like this.
Actually, it's probably the
top one, something like that,
might be.
I may not have matched exactly
what's in the textbook.
Cool.
One slight detail is I was
sort of waving my hands,
assuming there was
actually a cycle here.
I really only need a path.
In fact, there won't always be
a cycle because at the very end,
you're not able to
construct a cycle.
So that will actually
cause you to make--
if I do something like
this, so at least it
can connect to other things.
That will cause you make
two vertices of odd degree.
But that's OK
because there's still
an Euler path that starts at one
of the vertices of odd degree,
visits all the other
edges, and then,
comes to the other
vertex of odd degree.
And I just need a path.
You can actually characterize
when you get a cycle.
It's when the original thing
is not too colorable, I think.
Anyway, that's vertex unfolding.
It's kind of easy.
I think we solved most of
it in like an afternoon.
We had this idea.
It was cool, and then, we
solved it kind of quickly.
That's how it often goes.
Once you have a cool
problem, it falls quickly.
There's lots of interesting open
problems remaining about vertex
unfolding, and they
seem a lot harder.
So for example, what if I have
non-triangulated polyhedra?
And natural version is to think
about what we were originally
trying to attack,
convex polyhedra.
This turned out to
not require convexity.
But what about convex
polyhedra, not triangulated?
Is there always a
vertex unfolding?
We don't know about
edge unfoldings.
And the answer is no.
Well, no that's not right.
Sorry.
The answer is we don't know.
What's annoying
about this example
is that there's no facet-path.
So there are two things
that could go wrong.
One is that the
facet-path doesn't exist,
and that can happen in
this more general scenario.
And the other is that when
you lay it out, it overlaps.
Both of these things
could go wrong
in the general convex case.
So in this example, this
is a truncated cube.
There's eight triangles
and only six octagons.
And if you look, once
you're at a triangle,
you have to go to an
octagon because there's
no adjacent triangles.
So at best, you could alternate
triangle-octagon-triangle-octagon
if you want to pack all those
triangles in, but you run out
of octagons to get there.
So there's no facet-path,
but maybe, you
don't need facet-path.
You could make a tree,
just a little trickier.
Obviously, if you triangulate
that surface, you're done.
So the analog of general
unfolding with vertex unfolding
is trivial.
You just triangulate, and
then, you use the edge case.
But if you really only
want to cut along edges,
this example can be done.
I mean it has an edge unfolding,
so if it has an edge unfolding,
it definitely has
a vertex unfolding,
but we don't know
how to prove it.
The other thing that could
go wrong is once you have
octagons, even if you could
find a way to lay them out--
that's not a very good
octagon-- you can't-- let's say
if your two hinges
were here and here,
if that's where you attach
two adjacent pieces,
you can't fit that
in a vertical strip.
There's no way to turn it so
it fits in a vertical strip.
So also this layout
problem doesn't
work if you have something
more than triangles.
So some pretty
fascinating questions.
It's even open for non-convex.
If I take non-convex polyhedra,
and I want a vertex unfolding--
let's say all the
faces are convex.
At the very least, you need
to forbid faces having holes.
If you remember this
example, the box on a box,
this also doesn't have
a vertex unfolding
because still, this guy has to
fit in that little square hole.
But as long as the
faces don't have holes--
let's say the faces are convex--
would be a nice version,
like the Witch's Hat,
the spiked tetrahedron.
That probably has
a vertex unfolding.
AUDIENCE: If you triangulate
that, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If you
triangulate this,
it'll definitely have a--
if you triangulate anything,
it'll have a vertex unfolding.
Yeah.
All right.
That's all I want to say
about vertex unfolding,
and that's sort of addressing
edge unfolding of convex
polyhedra, or actually,
both of these.
Now, I'd like to go to
sort of the real problem.
This is one of my favorite
problems, I think.
A bunch of us posed it in '98,
which was right when I was--
or '99, right when
I was starting out.
See, it's tantalizing, in
some ways more natural,
because it's nice to
allow cuts anywhere.
And it could potentially
work for everything.
I conjecture every non-convex
polyhedron without boundary
can be generally
unfolded, and there's
some really good evidence for
this as of a couple years ago.
That's what I want
to talk about,
which is orthogonal polyhedra.
This is one of my favorite
unfolding results.
It's by Mirela Damian, Robin
Flatland, and Joe O'Rourke.
They've done a lot of work
in this unfolding area.
An orthogonal polyhedron is
one where all the faces are
perpendicular to one of
the three coordinate axes.
So for example, here is
a orthogonal polyhedron
I drew this morning.
If you want to draw
orthogonal polyhedra,
Google SketchUp
makes it really easy,
and you can add
shadows and texture.
So there are three
kinds of faces.
There's the ones perpendicular
to x, like these guys.
There's the ones
perpendicular to y.
That's all the yellow faces.
And there's the ones
perpendicular to z.
That's these top guys.
So we call them x-faces,
y-faces, z-faces.
What we're going to do--
so the theorem is these
have general unfoldings.
That's pretty awesome
because every polyhedron
is approximately orthogonal
if you can voxelize it.
So this is really
a lot of stuff.
I would love to generalize this
approach arbitrary polyhedra,
but that's the
big open question.
So what do we do?
Well, we're going to single
out, from this color coding,
the y-faces.
Just color them yellow.
Then, there's all
the other faces.
Well, they form bands.
They're cycles.
They go around in a loop.
A lot of them here, I've just
drawn as rectangular loops,
but in general, all those
wooden faces, the x and z-faces,
will form a bunch of loops.
And then, there's
the y-faces which
we're going to have to deal
with, but sort of ignore them
for a while.
I should have drawn
it with them erased.
It would look cool.
But if you think about
just those bands,
this is sort of how they're
connected together, this tree.
There's a big one out here,
and then, it has two children.
There's this one and this one.
And then, this child has
one child hanging off of it,
and this one has two
children hanging off of it.
So that's these two guys.
In general, this guy might
have some children hanging off
the back side as well.
I'm not going to try to
represent that in this picture.
There's just a
bunch of children.
There will be some
front children
and some back children.
You pick some root
arbitrarily, and then, you
have children
going off of there.
Now, if you're orthogonal
polyhedron has genus 0--
it's topologically a
sphere-- this will be a tree.
If it's like a doughnut,
it will have a cycle.
So this theorem only
applies for our genius zero.
So we're going to exploit
that that dual drawing, how
the bands are connected
together, is like a tree.
So why don't I
write down, a band
is a cycle of x and z-faces,
and they are connected together
in a tree.
Now, the rough
idea is we're going
to take a depth-first
traversal of this tree.
We're going to
start at the root,
work our way down and come
back, work our way down,
and something like that.
It's not going to
be quite so simple.
The challenge, I guess you
could say, is avoiding overlap.
OK?
If you wanted to unfold
a band, obviously, a band
can just unfold straight.
It's like a nice, long strip.
So each band,
individually, is fine.
It's how do you piece those
bands together and then,
have room for the
yellow faces to attach
on the sides, no overlap?
But it can be done with
the awesome, crazy idea
that we'll get to shortly.
It's going to start
out kind of innocent,
but the general
approach is always
proceed rightward
in the unfolding.
So the unfolding will
look something like this.
OK, whatever.
Always going to the right.
We start here, and we
might go up and down,
but we never go left.
And then, that's going
to be all the band faces.
All the band stuff will
be connected like that,
and then, there's going
to be yellow faces that
can just hang off the sides.
So these are the y-faces.
As long as I get
the band to do this,
y-faces can hang up and down.
It's not going to
intersect anybody.
Pretty clear?
So it's clear if
we could do this,
we can get non-selfintersection.
The amazing thing is
that this is possible.
What this is essentially
a limitation on
is how far you could
turn your bearing.
So you start going right.
You can turn right, but I
could not turn right again.
I have to turn left next.
I can actually do two
left turns in a row,
as long as I was
initially going down.
I can turn left twice, then,
I could alternate left-right.
That's always good.
Or I could turn right twice, but
only if I'm initially going up.
That's the rules.
As long as I adhere to
those rules, I'm fine.
Now, we're going
to heavily exploit
that we can do
general unfolding,
that we can subdivide
those strips
into lots of little pieces.
We're going to subdivide
into a lot of little pieces,
an exponential number of pieces,
so this is kind of hard core.
So here is one example.
This is a leaf.
So trees have leaves,
and at the end,
we're going to have
to visit a leaf.
So this is one box.
There's this funny
view, so you can
see like a mirror on the bottom
and a mirror on the right
and on the side.
So this is if you had one
box, here's what you would do.
And we're actually
assuming-- notice
this side does not get covered.
The idea is that
site doesn't exist.
That's attached to the
rest of the polyhedron,
so that's where
our parent lives.
And our parent tells us
you have to start at s,
and it says you
better finish at t.
And I want the property
that if initially,
I think, initially,
you're going right.
No, it looks like
initially, you're going up.
It matters.
You can do stuff,
and then, at the end,
you should still be facing up.
So you have to visit all these
faces, but not turn in total.
And normally, that
would be hard to do.
If you just tried to
visit one face at a time,
you can't do that,
but if you visit
faces multiple times and kind
of weave around in a clever way,
you can do it.
So maybe I'll point
with this thing.
Yeah.
So I start at s.
I go up.
I turn right.
Now, I better turn left.
I go down over here, up there.
I turn left.
Then, I turn right.
So if you follow along here,
I just turn right here.
So now, I go down here.
And that is a left
turn because it's
on the bottom, a little
hard to think about.
So I turn left here, and
then, I go, turn right.
And then, I go down, turn
left and then, right.
This is confusing
that I'm upside down.
And I come to t, and lo and
behold, I'm facing up again.
In fact, I basically
just zigzagged.
This would also work if
it was rotated 90 degrees.
I'd initially be going right
and, then, down and right
and down and right and down.
So this can kind
of go in a couple
of different orientations.
It's really powerful.
It also works if t is
on the other side of s.
You could do sort of the
mirror image traversal.
Now, obviously, I didn't
cover the entire surface.
I'm leaving room for
later, but if this
was all I was going to do, I
would actually sort of fill out
all those strips, just
kind of extend them.
It just makes this
kind of fatter.
So this got a little bigger.
I've got the first half
and then, the second half.
This is really glued up there.
But you can imagine once you
have these sort of paths that
visit everything,
you just fatten out,
and it's no big deal.
And also, in this
case here, we're
imagining-- oh, this is
actually two of them.
Fun.
Two of these strips
joined together.
And so there's a few side faces.
They just attach up and down.
They're not going to
intersect anything
because this is not
actually below this.
This is way over here.
So that's the
leaves, and I still
haven't gotten to
the exciting part.
So imagine you have a band.
Just going to represent
that by this big rectangle,
and it has a bunch of children.
Remember, it can
have front children.
This is down in
the y-coordinate.
And it could have back children
up in the y-coordinate.
And suppose I'm actually
attached to some parent,
let's say, as a down neighbor,
and I start at some s.
Let's say I'm told you
have to start here.
You have to finish here, and
you should preserve orientation
because I don't want to have to
think about whether it turned,
don't want to have
to depend on that.
So you can do it.
Initially, you must be facing
up because immediately I'm
going to make two right turns.
And I could handle
two right turns,
as long as the next
thing I did was a left.
So I come into
this thing saying,
look, you're facing--
this is facing up.
Now, you're facing down.
You better turn left
next, and by the end,
I still want to be facing down.
OK.
Now, I make two left turns.
Now, I'm facing up again.
I tell this guy, you better
turn right next, and preserve.
At the end, you should
be facing up again.
Now, I make two right turns.
Now, I'm facing down,
and so on and so on.
And here, I'm wrapping
around to here
because this is actually
a band that cycles around.
Then, I go in here.
It's the same thing.
It's just a little
hard to see because I'm
drawing it on a flat surface.
But if it was on a ring,
it would be much clearer.
Just going left and
right and left and right,
alternating direction, so that
I preserve my orientation.
At some point, I get to here.
I loop around.
I make a little
wiggle at some point,
and then, I can visit
all the top neighbors.
You just have to slightly switch
your orientation, but again,
preserve that you're doing
left-left-right-right,
left-left-right-right.
Then, you will preserve
your orientation.
You tell each of the children
which way you're initially
going, and they
can deal with it.
It's basically telling
you whether s and t
is like this or the
other way around.
OK?
So now, we end up
way up there where
the lavender edge is at t10.
Now what?
We want to come back
here, and I'm not
allowed to sort of
intersect myself.
That would be the paper
going into two parts
of this unfolding,
so that's not good.
But I have all this
space, so natural thing
is to just wander from
there back down to here,
using up the space.
So it's going to look like this.
Everything that you
did, you just undo.
Now, where this is
painful is not only
do I have to undo
it in this diagram,
but I have to recursively
undo everything
I did in here, everything I
didn't in here, and everything
I did in here.
So this recursive thing
from this structure
ends up getting doubled.
At the parent structure,
it will also get doubled.
At every level of
the tree, you're
going to double
what was below you,
so that's why you get
exponential, in general.
If your tree is ugly
like something like this,
you'll start with
something nice and small
down here, maybe
constant number of terms.
Then, you'll double.
Then, you'll double again.
Then, you'll double again,
and it will be exponential.
So if this is n, the number
of things you're doing here
is 2 theta n.
On the other hand,
if your tree happens
to be nice and balanced,
doubling is not so bad
because here you'll
have constant.
This will double
everything below.
This a double everything below,
but there's only log n levels.
So is that linear?
It should be about linear.
It's certainly 2
to the theta log n,
and it matters what
this constant is.
I think it's n or maybe n
squared, but not too bad.
So if you're lucky and the just
the structure of your bands
is balanced, it's good.
In general, though, it's
going to be exponential.
Open problem.
Can you deal with these
situations and sort of balance
them and make them only make
a polynomial number of cuts.
Certainly be nice.
Exponential number cuts
is a lot, but it works.
You can unfold every
orthogonal polyhedron this way.
I would love to see
an implementation
of this algorithm.
You could only do
it in a computer
because you'd be splicing
into all these little things,
and it would fall apart.
Jason?
AUDIENCE: You've been
making these, I guess,
gadgets [INAUDIBLE] voxel
would attach just by a side.
You could imagine it attaching
at a corner attaching
to multiple sides.
PROFESSOR: So you're worried
about-- not quite sure.
What we think about is one
band, which looks something
like this, attaching
to another band.
That will always
happen on a face.
I'm not quite sure
what you're imagining.
Maybe something like that where
they share a partial face here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
but it could also
be inset into the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If it's inset, I'm
cutting with every-- I maybe
didn't mention that--
through every vertex,
I'm going to slice
with a y-plane.
So that will cut into
lots of little strips,
and then, there's no sort
of overlap with the strips.
I'm subdividing into
little substrips.
So that sort of
deals with that issue
if this was moved that way.
Then, there will be
three strips, one
over here, one where
they're overlapping,
and one on the right.
Yeah.
Good question.
I forgot to mention the
subdivision at the beginning.
Speaking of subdivision
at the beginning,
this leads to another notion
which we call grid unfolding.
So the grid of an
orthogonal polyhedron
is what you get
when you subdivide
by extending every
face into a plane
and cutting with that plane.
So that's sort of
what I was doing here
when they're overlapping.
Even in this picture,
there's like a face here,
this vertical face,
and so I'd end up
slicing through this thing
with a band in that direction.
And I don't know,
this vertex you'll
end up slicing through this guy.
So hopefully, you
can imagine that.
With every vertex,
slice x, y, and z.
That's another way to do it.
And that subdivides
in sort of a nice grid
where every face will
now be a rectangle,
and rectangles always meet
whole edge to whole edge.
So it's a nice simplification.
What I'm proposing is add
those edges to your polyhedron.
It's kind of like assuming that
you started with unit cubes
and build something but kept
all the edges of all the cubes.
I want an edge
unfolding of that.
Do those exist?
These are what we
call grid unfoldings.
So grid unfolding is an
edge unfolding of the grid.
This only makes sense
for orthogonal polyhedra.
Open question.
Do grid unfoldings always exist?
It's essentially the
orthogonal analog
of this question, edge
unfolding a convex polyhedra.
If you want to go
to orthogonal, which
is like in between convex
and general non-convex,
maybe you could hope
for grid unfoldings.
Edge unfoldings
obviously don't work.
We had lots of examples
where those fail,
like the cube with little
bites taken out of the edges.
But grid unfolding, you
get lots of subdivision.
It might be easy.
Well, it's not easy.
I would guess, actually,
it's not possible.
The next best thing you
could hope for is to refine.
So you take each of
the grid rectangles
and divide it into
k by k, so subgrid.
So ideally, k is one, and
you're not subdividing at all.
But maybe, you take every
rectangle, divide it in half.
Maybe that's enough to
then be edge unfoldable.
That would be sort of a refined
level two grid-like unfolding.
There are a ton of
results about this.
They're all partial.
Obviously, in the
general situation--
I mean this algorithm
we just covered--
you can achieve a
refinement of only 2
to the theta n exponential.
When can you do better?
Ideally, you get 1 by 1, but
maybe, you can do something.
What?
OK.
Interesting.
One thing you could do, with
merely 5 by 4 refinement,
is something called
Manhattan Towers.
Let me show you a picture
of Manhattan Tower.
No that's not a picture
This is more crazy examples
of what it's like to visit.
This is not-- this
probably is complete,
but here, there isn't too much
doubling because there's only
a single child, more
or less, everywhere.
But the unfolding looks
something like that.
Here is Manhattan Tower.
So it has a connected
base on the x-y plane.
And I want to consider z-slices
as I go up in z-coordinate,
and I want those z-slices to
get smaller and smaller, always
contained in what I had before.
So I never have overhang.
That's a Manhattan Tower.
And in that case,
5 by 4 refinement
is enough to unfold
these things.
So that's pretty good, still
not perfect, but pretty good.
And this is by the same
authors, like a year
before the general result.
Let's see.
I think maybe I have a movie.
Yeah.
So this algorithm
has been implemented,
at least in some
simple examples.
And it kind of nicely unrolls.
You can see a 5 by 4 refinement
in that little staircase.
It's, again, to make everything
keep going to the right,
but here, they find a clever
way to visit all the faces
without having to revisit,
basically, at all,
just visiting each face a
constant number of times.
And then, we can zoom out,
and you get the unfolding.
So it looks very
similar in spirit.
Of course, the details is how
do you do all that visiting.
I'm not going to
cover that here,
but you get substantially
less refinement
for that special case.
Yeah.
Another case looks like this.
Boom!
AUDIENCE: Woah.
PROFESSOR: Isn't that cool?
I'll play it again.
This is just slightly
more special.
So again-- I have three of them.
They're so much fun.
It's like exploding a city.
Boom!
So here, the floor
is a rectangle.
That's the only
additional requirement,
and again, as you slice upwards,
things only get smaller.
Here's a bigger one.
Boom!
So exciting.
I could do this all day.
So I'm not going to
describe how this works,
but you could almost reconstruct
it from these diagrams.
This is what we call
an orthogonal terrain.
This result by Joe O'Rourke.
Here, you don't need any
refinement, grid unfolding, one
by one.
That's pretty sweet.
All right.
Next one is what we
call orthostacks.
These are like a stack of a
bunch of orthogonal polygons,
a bunch of bands, basically.
This is where the idea
of bands came from.
This is from an old paper
in 1998, from the beginning.
So it's just I have
a band, and then, I
stack another band on top.
So each z cross-section
is connected.
So that's a little different.
With towers, I could have
multiple towers here.
I really only want one
tower built slab by slab.
These things we don't
know how to grid unfold.
That's an open problem,
but if you refine just
in z by a factor of 2,
that's enough to unfold.
So 1 by 2 refinement is
enough for orthostacks.
Now, you could go
a little crazier
and allow vertex unfolding
of orthostacks with some grid
refinement, and in that case,
you don't need any refinement.
So grid vertex
unfolding orthostacks
was the title of paper.
These guys, John Iacono
and Stefan Langerman.
And it looks
something like this.
He uses vertex unfolding
to fix the direction.
Here you were going up, but
you really wanted to go right.
So it makes things easier.
And in fact, the other
guys, Damian, Flatland,
and O'Rourke-- It's got to
be awesome doing geometry
and your last name is
Flatland, unless she
does a lot of three
dimensional stuff.
Irony.
You can do vertex grid unfolding
of any orthogonal polyhedron
is what I have written here.
I haven't actually read that.
I should read that paper.
What else do I have?
Orthotubes.
Orthotubes, this is
again in the old paper.
Orthotube is just sort of
thickness one orthogonal tube.
It could even be closed,
I think, in a loop,
but here I've shown it open.
And here, grid
unfolding is enough.
You just do all the
grid refinement.
You could even
just do it locally.
Technically,
there's a slice here
that might slice
over here, but you
don't have to worry about that.
You just subdivide
into a bunch of boxes,
and this can be unfolded in
a sort of zigzag fashion.
So 1 by 1.
You can generalize
this to trees also,
though, it's not totally known.
As long as you have
a tree of cubes
with fairly long connectors
in between the branch points--
those are called
well-separated orthotrees--
that works grid unfolding.
If you don't have
that condition,
so just have cubes connect
in some treelike fashion,
it's open whether you
can do a grid unfolding.
We've worked on
that in the past.
My conjecture's, in general,
you need to omega n refinement.
My belief is that this
kind of exponential blow
up is necessary, but that you
can do it only a balance tree.
So this would give
like linear refinement.
I think that's necessary,
but we can't even
prove that you need 2 buy 1
refinement in any example.
We don't have anything where
grid unfolding is definitely
impossible.
It's quite sad state, I guess.
It's very hard to prove that
there aren't unfoldings, accept
by exhaustive
enumeration, and that's
hard to do because it's slow.
We've come up with lots
of candidate examples,
but eventually, we
unfold them all.
I have a bunch of
other open problems.
This was genus 0.
Interesting question is can
you do genus higher than 0?
Orthogonal polyhedra.
I would guess so,
but I'm not sure.
I think the biggest
question is, can you
make this non-orthogonal?
But then, the bands get messy.
Haven't been able to do that.
All right.
I think those were
the main problems.
Any questions?
I'm going to take a
break from unfolding now
and switch the other
direction of folding.
So with folding, we're imagining
we're given some polygon,
and we'd like to make
a polyhedron out of it.
It's exactly the reverse of
what we've been thinking about.
When is this possible?
Now, the rules of the game here
are different from origami.
With origami, we
showed from any shape,
you can make anything
if you scale it down.
But here, I really
want exact coverage.
Every point here, or let's
say every little patch here,
should be covered by
exactly one layer over here,
not allowing multiple layers.
So this means not
everything is possible.
I also care about
scale factor, but--
This one, of course, you
can crease like this,
and more importantly, you
glue these edges together.
You glue these edges together.
The opposite of
cutting is gluing.
We'll be more formal about
defining gluing, I think,
next lecture.
This is just a sort of prelude.
But you end up gluing--
I want to make something,
let's say-- in
fact, we're always
going to talk about
folding convex polyhedra.
There's very little work
on the non-convex case,
though, there was
actually a recent result.
I'll mention that next lecture.
If you want to make
something convex,
and therefore,
sphere-like, you have
to get rid of all the
boundary, so you've got a glue
every edge.
You don't have to glue
whole edges to whole edges.
Maybe you just glue
part of an edge
to another part of an
edge, but somehow, boundary
has to get glued up.
And if you want something
sphere-like, in fact,
those gluings have
to be non-crossing.
I have to be able to
draw a picture like this.
Question is when do these
gluings make a polyhedron?
That is the question we will
be answering next class.
But first question is suppose I
gave you one of these pictures.
I give you a polygon,
and I give you a gluing.
What this tells you is sort
of how to locally walk around.
So if I'm here, I
could walk over here.
I could walk over here, teleport
over there, walk over here,
teleport over here.
Whatever.
OK?
The gluing tells you locally
what the surface looks like,
even though you don't know
what it looks like yet in 3D.
In particular, you can
compute shortest paths here.
I could compute the shortest
path from this point
to this point you might
think is a straight line.
But no, it's not.
I don't think.
Or maybe it is.
Let's see.
A little tricky.
AUDIENCE: Should be diagonal
with the bottom square.
PROFESSOR: Diagonal
with the bottom square
because these guys are
both in the bottom.
Very good.
So this point is the same as
this point, or no, this point.
Because these get
zipped together.
This point is the
same as this point,
so in fact, that diagonal is the
shortest path between those two
points.
So you have to think
about it for a while,
but it turns out, in polynomial
time, you can do that.
That's cool.
What I want to show
now is that suppose
you could make a convex
polyhedron in this way.
I claim you can only make
one, never more than one
from the same gluing.
So I've defined locally
what this thing is.
It's like a piece of paper.
I can mangle it around.
If I want to make
something convex,
there's only one thing
it could possibly make.
Finding out what that one
thing is quite a challenge,
but at least, we can
prove that it's unique.
Sorry about the screeching.
This is Cauchy's
rigidity theorem.
I think we mentioned it
in a previous lecture when
we were talking about
rigidity and three dimensions
and like why domes stand up.
But now, we're going to use it.
We're actually going
to prove this theorem,
and we're going to use it to
study these kinds of gluings
and say there's, at
most, one way to do this.
There's a lot of ways
to state this theorem,
but one way is to say, suppose
you have two convex polyhedra,
and suppose they came
from the same sort
of intrinsic geometry.
So there's the
geometry of the faces,
and there's how they're
connected together.
So here, initially,
I drew a tree
of how the faces were
connected together,
and then, I drew some other
connections like this.
So the dual here is, of
course, an octahedron.
But if you have two
convex polyhedra
and they are combinatorally
equivalent, they
have the same way that
things are connected
together, the same graph, and
they have congruent faces,
so the geometries
match also, then, they
are actually the same
thing, the same polyhedron.
AUDIENCE: Is that
something that--
PROFESSOR: Up to
rotation and translation.
AUDIENCE: Is it the same
set of congruent faces?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
So when I say
congruent faces, I mean
according to this equivalence.
If you take a face
on one that has
a corresponding
face on the other,
those two faces should be
congruent, not just any pair,
and they're not all the same.
Different faces
can be different,
but they're identical in pairs.
So I'm just saying basically,
if you have this picture,
there's only one realization.
So this picture defines what
are the geometry of the faces,
how are they connected together.
And so if you had
two convex polyhedra
with that same
underlying diagram,
they have to be the
same polyhedron.
That's what we're claiming.
That's what we're
going to prove.
Is this one any better?
Yeah, it's better.
This is an old theorem.
You may have heard of Cauchy,
famous French mathematician.
Cauchy-Schwarz inequality,
all those good things.
You don't need to know those.
He proved a lot of things.
This theorem he
didn't actually prove.
He wrote a paper about it
or, I think, partly a letter,
partly a paper in 1813.
Proof was wrong, and
it was fixed in 1934,
over 100 years
later, by Steinitz.
So sometimes it's called
Cauchy-Steinitz rigidity
theorem, although,
usually, Cauchy.
There's a lemma in
here that's often
attributed to both of them.
So it's sort of a
proof by contradiction.
We want to prove uniqueness.
So we're supposing,
well, maybe, there's
two polyhedra, p and
p prime, and they're
combinatory equivalent and
have matching faces congruent.
What I want to do is look
at corresponding vertices,
let's say a vertex v and p and
a vertex v prime and p prime.
So there corresponding in the
combinatorial equivalence.
And then, I want to
slice the polyhedra, p
and p prime, with
an epsilon sphere,
epsilon radius sphere
centered at v and v prime.
Quick mention, this
is not true if you
allow non-convex realizations.
You may have seen
that example before.
These have exactly the same
combinatorial structure,
same geometry on each
face, but one's non-convex,
and they're different.
But as long as they're convex,
they're going to be the same.
In a convex situation, here's
what the slice looks like.
So here's little
vertex, degree like 5,
and I slice the polyhedron
with this tiny sphere centered
at v, not the interior, just
the boundary of the sphere.
What I get are these arcs.
They'll be great circular arcs.
Here we can see
all five of them.
They're great circular arcs.
There on the sphere.
I get a polygon.
I get a convex
polygon on the sphere.
Convex spherical
polygons, convex
because the
polyhedra are convex.
I actually get two of them.
Right?
One for p, one for p prime.
Polygons.
What do I know about
those polygons?
I know they're edge lengths
because the length of an edge
here is equal to-- if
this is a unit sphere,
if I rescale the
epsilon to be 1,
that edge length is
actually this angle.
That angle is an angle of
the face at the vertex.
So I know all the angles.
I know all the
geometries of the faces.
I know they're congruent.
So I know what these edge
lengths are in the sphere.
What I don't know are these
angles of the polygon.
I know the lengths
of the polygon,
but I don't know the
angles of the polygon
because that's essentially the
dihedral angle of that edge.
And the worry is, well, maybe
all the edge lengths match.
We could do this
at every vertex,
but maybe the dihedral
angles are different.
Maybe the convex
polyhedron could flex.
That's why this
is about rigidity.
Maybe it's flexible,
and then, maybe there
are two different states.
All the faces are the same,
and therefore, all those edge
lengths are the same, but
the angles might differ.
If p and p prime are
supposed to be different,
then there must be two
angles that differ.
So I want to look
at those angles,
and I want to label vertex
of a spherical polygon.
So I have n of these spherical
polygons for p n of them
and p prime.
Let's look at them in p.
I'm going to label it plus if
the angle there in p is bigger
than the angle in p prime.
Remember I have a correspondence
between everything
in p and everything and p prime.
Minus, if the angle is less,
and 0, if the angles are equal.
So what I want to
show is actually
all the angles are equal.
Therefore, the polyhedra
will be identical.
If all the faces are the same
and all the angles at which you
join them are the same
and they're connected
in the same way, they
are the same polyhedron.
There's no flexibility
there, but it
could be there are
pluses and minuses.
But if there's going to be
a problem with this theorem,
there have to be
pluses and minuses.
That's the proof
by contradiction.
So let's look at one of them.
Let's look at a vertex that
has some pluses or minuses.
So we have-- it's a
spherical polygon.
I'm going to draw it more like
a polygon, maybe some pluses,
some zeroes, some
minuses, whatever.
First question is could it
be all pluses and zeroes?
Is that possible?
No.
It doesn't look good.
What does that mean?
It would mean this
is like a linkage.
We're used to linkages.
It just happens
to be on a sphere.
Forget this on a sphere.
Think of it is as almost flat.
What that would mean is
there's some other way
to draw this thing.
Basically, there's a
way to flex this linkage
so that all of these angles
increase and this one
stays the same.
How could I get a polygon
where all the angles increase
and still be convex?
Ain't possible.
Why is it not possible?
I think we've used this
fact a couple lectures ago.
It's not possible by something
called the Cauchy Arm Lemma.
This is the part that
Cauchy got wrong,
so it's also called the
Cauchy-Steinitz Arm Lemma.
And here's the thing.
If you have a convex
chain but open chain here.
There's a missing bar.
So suppose that even
when you add the bar,
it's a convex polygon.
But then, I take a convex
polygon, remove an edge.
This is what we
call convex chain.
And if you open all the angles,
increasing all the angles,
in a convex chain, then
this distance increases.
It's pretty intuitive.
I open all these angles.
So I put plus.
Some of them could
stay the same,
but then, this
distance will increase,
as long as you stay convex.
I should mention that.
But in this situation, we know
that both the initial position
in p and its target position
in p prime are both convex.
OK.
Let's just take
that lemma as given.
This is the one I don't like.
Then, I know, in particular,
I can't have all pluses
because then, if I just pretend
one of these edges wasn't here,
I know that that
distance must increase.
But it can't increase.
It's supposed to stay the same.
The edge lengths are fixed.
So if they're all pluses
and zeroes, or all minuses
and zeroes, the same is true
just viewing p prime as p and p
as p prime.
They can't be all pluses.
They can't be all minuses.
So if there's anything in
there other than zeroes,
there has to be at least one
plus, at least one minus.
In particular, there have to
be at least two alternations.
Alternation is either going
from plus to minus or from minus
to plus.
So it could be
something like plus,
plus, plus, minus, minus,
minus, minus, plus, plus.
Whatever.
OK?
Maybe that's your polygon,
and that's your labeling.
Is that possible?
So once you have at least
one plus and one minus,
you have to have these
two switches at least.
Could this happen?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Right.
Because you pick some chord.
What do I do here?
Just subdivide.
All right.
Whatever.
Pick some chord like this one.
I'm not sure it matters.
Maybe here?
Whatever.
These angles down
here are decreasing.
Therefore, this
distance decreases.
The angles up here
are all increasing.
Therefore, this
distance increases.
Can't have both.
So this is also not possible.
So in fact, you have to have
at least four alternations.
It's always even.
And so it has to be at least a
bunch of pluses, then a bunch
of minuses, then a
bunch of pluses, then
a bunch of minuses.
And so we're counting these
transitions from plus to minus.
This is a lemma that we used
when we were locking trees,
I think.
We had a convex polygon.
I said at least two of the
angles have to decrease,
or at least two of them have to
increase, one way or the other.
That's because there have to be
at least two groups of pluses,
not only at least two pluses
and at least two minuses.
You might think,
well, what happens
if there's only three vertices.
Then, you can't have
these four alternations.
Well, yeah, you can't have
those four alternation
because if you have a
triangle, even on the sphere,
triangles are rigid.
So you would know if I had
a degree 3 vertex, locally
that thing is rigid.
It can't flex at all.
We're only interested in cases
where it might flex locally
at a vertex like the pentagon,
like a quadrilateral.
All right.
So what?
This was true at every vertex
that was not entirely zero.
So if we look at-- let
me write this down.
I really just care about
the non-zero edges,
the ones that are plus or minus.
So I'll call the subgraph
of plus and minus edges.
The number of alternations
is at least 4 times
the number of vertices.
I'm going to denote the number
of vertices by a capital V. OK?
That's page one.
We're going to use a trick.
It has many names, I suppose.
I usually call it double
counting in combinatorics,
where you have one
quantity, namely,
the number of alterations.
We're going to count it
in two different ways.
We'll get two different
answers, but we
know they must end
up being the same.
And then, we'll get
a contradiction.
So what's the second
way of counting.
Well, we counted
local to a vertex.
The other natural
way to count angles
is by looking at the faces.
There are also faces.
It's sort of the
dual perspective.
Every phase has a bunch of
angles that have some degree
or whatever.
They're really kind
of the same thing.
Oh, here was Cauchy's Arm Lemma.
Beautiful.
If you look at the
alternations as you
walk around a vertex versus
as you walk around a face,
you'll end up counting
them the same number.
Right?
Here was an alternation
from plus to minus.
What's interesting
here-- before we
were thinking of
labeling the vertices
of the spherical polygon, but in
fact, whatever this edge does,
it does the same thing local to
that vertex as the thing local
to that vertex.
So really the labels are
on the edges of the graph.
They could be zero,
plus, or minus.
And if I have an alternation
from plus to minus,
view from the vertex,
it's also an alternation
as I walk around the face.
So instead of counting
by walking around all
the vertices-- which are just
did, and I got at least four
at every vertex-- let's
do it from the perspective
of the faces.
And we're in this weird subgraph
of plus and minus edges,
so assume there are no zeroes.
All right.
If I have a face of 2
k or 2 k plus 1 edges,
then it will have, at
most, 2 k alternations.
So I already have a lower
bound number of alternations.
I'm going to try and
prove an upper bound,
sandwich it between, and show
that, actually, the upper bound
is smaller than the lower bound,
and that's a contradiction.
So this is kind of obvious.
Right?
If you have 2 k vertices, no
more than 2 k alternations,
slight, the place where we're
making a little improvement
is for the odd case.
We know because a
number of alterations
has to be even you can't get
up to 2 k plus 1 alternations.
Has to be even because
for every plus to minus,
there has to be a matching minus
to plus because it's cyclic.
So even here, you can
only get 2 k alternations.
That helps us a little
bit because now, we
can talk about
number of alternation
is at most two times
the number of triangles,
f sub 3 is going to be the
number of faces of degree 3,
plus 4 times the number
of quadrilaterals
plus 4 times the
number of pentagons
plus 6 times the number
of hexagons plus--
why'd I write seven?
I wrote seven.
I'm being sloppy.
At that point, I don't care.
7 f 7, 8 f 8, 9 f
9-- I'm not going
to try to be clever
from 6 on, but I'm
going to be clever at 5 and 3.
Why 5 and 3?
As you may remember
from way back
when, you have a planar
graph-- because polyhedra
are planar graphs.
They're convex.
The average degree is 5?
Slightly under 6, 4, 3, 2, 1?
One of those numbers.
Let's see.
Should be like 3 n minus 6
edges, so that should be 3.
Yeah, three.
So most of the faces are
going to have low degree.
That's the points.
So 3 and 5 really
matter, but out here, it
doesn't matter so much.
This is kind of a magical proof.
It shouldn't be intuitive
where it came from,
but it's really beautiful.
You'll see as it
all comes together.
Fun.
What do I do next?
Right.
I want to relate-- I
have a vertex count here.
I have a face count here,
and I know Euler's formula.
Hopefully, we know it.
It's a cool formula.
V minus E plus F is 2.
This is the number of
vertices, number of edges,
number faces is two.
[? For ?] connected,
planar graphs.
There are other versions when
you have multiple components
or when you have
tori, genus, whatever,
but for convex
polyhedra, this is true.
So this conveniently
relates vertices to faces,
but it involves edges.
So somehow, I have to
bring edges into the mix.
All right.
Well, edges.
I want to count
the number of edges
in terms of the number of faces.
I could do it in terms
of vertices or faces.
The number of edges
is half the sum
of the degrees of the vertices.
Remember, that's handshaking
lemma from way back when.
It's also half the sum of
the degrees of the faces.
If I look at every face and
I count the number of edges,
I will end up counting
every edge twice, once
from each side, so this is
half the number of faces.
Well, number faces I want
to write in this form.
So this is half 2-- No, sorry.
Not the number faces.
What am I doing?
Half the sum of the
degrees of the faces.
So this is half-- what is
the degree of degree 3 faces?
3.
What is the degree
of degree 4 faces?
4.
And so on.
Exactly.
So now, things are
starting to look similar,
and I want to get some
cancellation going on.
Use my cheat sheet here.
I'm going to
rewrite this formula
as V equals 2 plus E minus F.
Hopefully, that's the same.
I put E over here.
I put F over there.
We'll get this.
OK.
So now, I have E
minus F. E is this.
F-- I have F. Am I
missing something here?
I'll write the
next one, and I'll
figure out where it came from.
Oh, duh, I just skipped a step.
F is the sum of f3 plus
f4 plus f5 plus f6.
OK?
All I did here was
decrease by-- well,
because there's a half out here,
I decrease each coefficient
by 2, nothing surprising.
Whew!
So I took E, I subtracted F,
just took away one of each.
Now, I have this formula.
That's V.
Now, I also know
that 4V is at most,
the number of alternations.
Hm.
So I could get a
formula for 4V here.
Right?
4V is going to be 8 plus
this is going to be like 2.
So I get 2 f3 plus-- oh
boy, 1 times-- 4 times f4
plus-- just double
these numbers-- 6 times
f5 plus-- what's the next one?
4-- 8 times f6, and so on.
Yes.
OK.
Now, these guys look very
similar to these guys.
Now, here it gets bigger.
8.
It's going to go 10,
instead of 6 and 7.
We also have a plus 8.
We don't know whether there
any faces of degree 6 or more,
so we can't rely on
that, but we have plus 8.
So somehow, 4V,
which is, at most,
the number of
alternations-- that's
the reverse of what
we said before-- 4V
is, at most, this
number, and yet, it's
also equal to this number.
It can't be both.
This number's at least 8
larger than this number.
It could be even more
larger, but at least
that contradiction done.
This works as long as
there's at least one face,
meaning there's at
least 1 plus or minus
because we're only looking at
the subgraph plus and minus
edges.
And that is Cauchy's
rigidity theorem.
Let me quickly tell
you in our situation,
here, we don't actually
necessarily know
where the creases are.
We just know how things
are glued together.
Even in that situation,
you could sort of
figure out where the creases
must be because as I said,
you can compute shortest paths
once you have the gluing.
So you compute
the shortest paths
between all pairs of vertices,
something like this picture,
except you don't know
what it looks like in 3D.
You can still compute
the shortest paths.
You know every edge
must be a shortest path.
So the edges are some
subset of these guys.
And so you've got lots of
little convex polygons here.
We know it must make
a convex polyhedron.
If it made two, Cauchy's
rigidity theorem
would tell you that
they're the same.
So even once you
fix the gluing, you
know that there's a
unique convex realization,
and there will be a unique
set of edges from the shortest
paths that actually realize it.
The next class will
be all about how
to actually find those gluings
and know that they actually
will fold into some convex shape
and how to find that convex
shape, but that's it for today.